look if you don't figure this out you're
[__] you're broke
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what yeah what's up sean why
we keep getting two things that's kind
of like keeping me up at night the first
which doesn't keep me up at night but
weirds me out why do people keep
confusing us
and the second thing and the second
thing that does keep me up at night
is i don't know if they're saying it
just about me or about both of us but
they say that we look
differently
yeah and i think both are like i think
both are insults wrapped in disguise
like they're not saying anything bad
but the way they're kind of like
laughing
makes me think uh it's not a it's not a
good thing i don't think it's an
upgrade for them
someone said that i write like a bro but
i look like a nerd
and i'm like you're you're you're
insulting
both my looks and i like
how do you make me look i want to look
like a bro maybe and talk
or wait which one do i want to do i want
to look like a bro and talk and and talk
like a nerd maybe
that's hilarious um um yeah so it's
people mix up that means for months
they've just been listening to this and
they think i'm you and they think you're
me and when they follow us
they uh you know
they have it all wrong it's kind of
funny and then
um i have uh do you know what e foiling
it
what what's e foil what are you talking
about i'm about to rent one so it's a
twelve thousand dollar
device and it looks kind of like a wake
board
but it has like a three foot to four
foot
like rudder that sticks on the bottom of
it and on the bottom of that rudder is a
motor
and it's like a boosted skateboard with
like a with like a handheld
acceleration device and it you lift off
and it
you ride three feet above the water i've
seen this
uh now that you say i thought you were
talking about something related to like
i don't know microphones or voices you
just switched topics uh
with a hard left turn but i appreciate
that so i saw this because what's the
name of that one surfer guy who's like
uh super famous laird hamilton
yeah laird hamilton i saw him doing this
where he was go i don't know if his i
think his was like even taller
but basically he was surfing with you
know
there's like a there's like an
underground fin and then he's elevated
above the water
and he was like and there's it's like a
jet ski that he's standing on it was
kind of crazy
sounds like that's what this is yeah
well i'm about to go do it in an hour
i'm pumped this is the next before we
get into ideas
it might be it might be there i'm
getting ads for it constantly on social
media it might be
um we have a good episode today because
you brought something up incredibly
interesting and i do
i went deep on it but before we get into
that can i tell
you a quick story yeah go for it okay so
a few weeks ago i got mocked on the
internet for like doing this trapped in
a closet
for with andrew chen thing so this guy
named andrew chen
what is a partner at andreessen horowitz
he's got a cool startup e blog
but i heard he told me one of the wilder
stories i've heard
recently so when he was in i think
i could i might get uh some of the
details like wrong by year or two
but when he was in about sixth grade he
took the sat
and scored really high and when he did
i think it's the university university
of washington does this thing where
every five or ten
they take five or ten students per year
who are in sixth or seventh grade
sometimes younger like 12 years old
whichever grade that is and they asked
them to come to college to come to
university of washington
and he was one of the students and so
he at sixth grade i think he skipped
seventh grade and went straight to
college and he
moved there in a dorm went to college
and i asked him who else was in it and
he actually said emmett emmett shear
from twitch was one of the folks
wait wait so he didn't go to college he
didn't like become a college student he
just went for like a camp or something
or he's no
he's like no doogie houser stuff like he
literally
instead of going to seventh grade he
moved into a dorm
went to college and and here's where it
gets
even crazier so he like moved there
moved away from home which i think his
parents are from the state as well but
it was like moved half an hour however
far away from home lived there as a
college student
and he understandably was kind of
embarrassed
and didn't really tell a lot of people
and so they thought that
even though he was however whatever age
you are in seventh grade
they kind of assumed that he was just
another 18 year old and apparently he
told me that he even dated a girl
he um just kind of acted normal and they
didn't find out
that he didn't like hide it from them
but he didn't bring it up and they
didn't find out until
senior year or something like that when
everyone was turning 21 and they were
like when you turned 21 he was like oh
i'm
i'm actually 17 years old or six
whatever 16 yeah
and i it's a pretty wild story and i
asked him like who else was part of this
program he said the founder of twitch
was
some person running a huge hedge fund
just like baby genius
like real baby geniuses crazy
fascinating story
and apparently the university of
washington still does
this every year where they select i
forget what they call the program but
it's like a thing where they
have psychologists and therapists meet
with the kids every
quarter every month to discuss what's
going on
and it was incredibly fascinating and in
a very typical
genius response i said isn't that weird
that you
skipped high school and he was like well
what do you think about it adolescence
is really just like a societal
constraint
and i kind of experienced the same thing
i was like oh yeah i mean i guess you're
right but
like thanks for proving my point that
you are just a figment of my imagination
um yeah isn't that wild that is wild
also i don't know if that's true because
emmett definitely went to yale and so
did justin khan so i don't know
well maybe it was through yale but he
said that emmett was part of the same
program or maybe he dropped out
um but he said that
age 13. i love it we said that emmett
was part of
his program i i don't know what if
program that they do in a ton of
different schools
but like a uh 13 year old freshman in
college
uh would you let your kid do this or
would you want your kid to do this let's
say your kid's 12
scores high on a test would you want him
to skip high school and
go and be a 13 year old college student
and like amongst the you know
amongst the crazy 18 year olds so it's a
good question because
your my gut instinct is probably the
same as everyone else's which is high
school is important you learn
uh about yourself and and it's important
to go through all that normal stuff
but we also complain that high school
often or that like what you learn in
high school is kind of [__]
and and you know
what does the world look like if you do
combine the two so like maybe it is
i don't so i don't know but isn't that
isn't that a wild story
yeah that that's crazy i um uh such a
fun fact about someone
yeah i also think it's an interesting
strategy for the colleges like why are
they doing this um i think it's
kind of cool i remember the reason i
ended up going to duke is because they
had this thing called the
tip program which is the talent
identification program
and you would take the i don't know the
psats or something like that
and then if you scored above a certain
thing duke would send you this kind of
like kit
this goody bag and it basically was like
it felt like getting an
owl from hogwarts and it's like hey
you're 12
and like we want to invite you to this
special school for the gifted and
talented
and it just said like you scored high on
this we have identified you as a
talented
person we would love to you know like
have you come visit our campus and like
eventually
and the [__] worked i went to duke
eventually i didn't put two two together
that's why but like
if i think about it that's why i started
paying attention to them and that's why
i started following the basketball teams
that's how i even heard about it
otherwise as a 12 year old kid you don't
even you don't even hear about colleges
right so
i thought that was pretty interesting
and if you think about it you know these
schools are for-profit these schools are
trying to get
um you know they're trying to get
tuition they're trying to get people to
come in and pay the uh 40 50 grand
to go to school and so these little
investments
um and and you know who doesn't like to
be called
talented who doesn't like to be called
kind of like a phenom uh what parent
doesn't want their kid to be identified
as a special
um that [__] works and i'm surprised
that more schools don't do this and when
i start my school i
i too am gonna do this yeah i'm i'm
trying to like do some research on it
right now what we're talking and it's
not really effective but
uh you'll have to look up this program
when you're done it's just a really cool
interesting thing
uh and it was funny to meet someone who
went through it and it was just such a
silly fun fact about someone
by the way my roommate in college um we
when he got when we got to college i was
like yeah yeah you know we're all 17 or
18 whatever we were as freshmen
and he was like yeah like um he would
say like yeah but then like i noticed
this expression i was like well
what he's like well i'm like 19 and a
half about to turn 20.
and i was like what why are you so old
and basically
they do the exact opposite when it comes
to sports so in sports
uh the common thing to do is to like
sandbag your kid and basically
hold your kid back a grade or like send
them to school a year late
so that they're always bigger faster
stronger than all the other kids
in their grade and you're always like
the star athlete because
you have like an extra year of
development or you have a better shot i
should say of being a star athlete
and so he was from wyoming and he's like
oh dude in wyoming this is
that's par for the course dude every you
know every sixth grader is like an
eighth grader's age
because everybody wants to like have
their kid be yeah
my first two years of college i was an
athlete and i would compete against
these guys and there was two groups of
people that we would like and i was
friends with them but we would tease
about
they're not really it's like it's a
little unfair which is the first was
kenyan so kenyan runners
um i think that there's i don't know i
don't know i don't think they were lying
about their age but i think there's a
an exemption if you serve in the
military so you get to compete in
college
and college athletics i think until
you're this was ten years or eight years
ago however long
you get to compete until you're 26 years
old
um and then the second is for um
religious stuff so the mormons
at age 18 would bounce for two years so
they would be a 20 year old freshman
which means there'd be a 24
year old senior in college so i was 18
my freshman year competing against 24 25
year olds
and so yeah mo the mormons and the in
the kenyans if they
and uh anyone served in the military and
uh i know this topic is basically nobody
gives a [__] about what we're talking
about but i will say there is a lesson
uh that's in life you get to choose are
you gonna punch up or punch down
and uh the andrew chen thing going to
college at 12 or 13 that's a kid who's
punching up
you're you know you're in an unfamiliar
circumstance you're stretching
beyond you know what you what you're
playing
in the bigger leagues than where you are
and then there's the uh
athletes that are that are held back
years or you know come back and compete
against people
you know two to five years younger than
them that's punching down in weight
and i would say like punching down has
some benefits
because typically you're gonna score
better do better
um in these little like games you know
in you know high school or college
athletics
but in the end you really want to be
somebody who punches up uh you always
want to
i think you know for long-term success
you want to be somebody who punches up
who somebody somebody who's always
in a room where you're just barely
hanging on because it'll push you to get
better more so than just dominating
people because you're older and stronger
than them well it works for andrew chen
i think he's 38 years old but i was like
but you're really like 45
[Laughter]
right like in my experience like a 45
year old
all right let's get to the top first
full-time job okay let's get to the
first one so
sean put something on here that i
actually think i was telling
a friend as i was researching i actually
think that this is one of the better
ideas
that we and you you've ever come up with
the michael jordan thing all right
yeah you want me to explain it okay so
um
i've been looking at this house for a
long time michael jordan's house has
been for sale for like a decade and it
hasn't sold
and this is his house uh kind of like
you know in illinois near chicago where
you know michael jordan was on the bulls
and he had this 56
000 square foot home in highland park
and so this thing originally he put it
up for sale
and like i don't know nine years ago for
30 million dollars 29 million dollars
and now it's you know the price has been
cut in half
and the thing is still not selling and
if you look at the photos you can just
go it's like on zillow
so you can go look at the photos he's
got like an indoor basketball court
you know the gate leading up to the
driveway has his big 23 number
like embossed in it he's got you know
everything you would want like
huge you know closets because he's got
you know all his air jordans or whatever
and so his house is it's pretty
unbelievable
right there's there's all kinds of um
epic [__] here
but it's not selling and it's not
selling for i think a couple reasons
it's like you know
it's very custom to michael jordan um
like it just it's like
it was custom made in many senses so you
know that other rich people don't
necessarily want to live in a house
that's like made for another dude
um it's also you know it's very
expensive for the area
the property taxes are really expensive
all that stuff but
i was thinking okay the price is now cut
in half now it's now it's a 13 million
dollar house or a 12
you know 13 million home that you could
buy
13 14 and now it's in range where
maybe there's something fun you could do
with it now you might be getting a value
by so i was thinking
all right there's a bunch of people
obviously that are basketball fans that
love michael jordan
um there's a bunch of you know new ways
to crowdfund that we've been talking
about nfts or
kickstarter or different different
crowdfunding platforms so
the question is should we buy michael
jordan's house
should we start a crowdfunding campaign
and buy michael jordan's house so if you
could get
5 000 people to each put in 2 500
then you could own a fractional share of
michael jordan's house
you could you you could own a piece of
of this history
and we could just buy it out take it off
the market
and we could own this thing and then the
question is like what do you do with it
um and so i wanted to brainstorm with
you a should we buy michael jordan's
house and
b what could we do with it if we did buy
it what do you think
so the whole nft thing i wouldn't do
that
i think that i think you've had two
ideas here one is to buy his house and
two is to end do the nft thing
uh one of those ideas is great i think
the other one is over complicating it
i would 100 buy it and the reason why i
think it's such a great
idea is immediately after you seeing you
write this
my thought right away went to graceland
you know what graceland is
no that's funny that you don't know what
that is it's because it's such a big
deal
in my family or elvis is at least so
graceland
is elvis presley's house uh it's in
memphis
it's in downtown memphis it's actually
in a pretty crappy neighborhood now
or the neighborhood is not nice and it's
like
kind of gross but it's just like a
cutesy thing to do if you visit memphis
and i went and did research on it and so
around
600 000 people a year go to graceland
which brings in something like where i
have the numbers here
okay so graceland just in attendance uh
just in ticket sales
brings in 21 million dollars so it's
yeah pretty wild just on tickets and
then 600
000 visitors a year uh 36
a ticket right yes and i got interested
in this so i thought
what are the most visited homes in
america so i came up with a few and i
want to fill you in on them so
the white house doesn't count because
you can just you i think you can get a
tour but you could also just walk
outside of it but
graceland 600 thousand the second one
i'm you guys are gonna make fun of me i
don't know how to pronounce this what is
it monticello
i think so okay monticello that's uh
thomas jefferson's house
and so the interesting thing about this
place as well as a few other i'm going
to mention is that they're non-profits
which means all of their numbers are
public
and so uh the revenue for monticello
which includes a ton of investment
revenue was around
200 million dollars in 2010
but around uh eight million seven
million came just from ticket sales
so eight million a year in ticket sales
which is crazy and they have around 500
000 people
another uh most visited home is never uh
like homes that people drive by
neverland ranch people don't go there
but the other another great one is mount
vernon which is uh i think
uh what's our first president george
washington's house
uh and they do in
in in uh food sales alone
this is crazy just in food 17 million
dollars a year
wow is that crazy insane the whole
operations
and then they do 15 million dollars a
year in admission sales
and in total they do about 51 million
dollars a year
in total income which includes 10
million from contributions
is that crazy no that's absolutely
insane so let me ask you
these okay so this all of a sudden this
starts to get really interesting right
because i think michael jordan is on par
with elvis and
you know thomas jefferson michael
jordan's got tj beat by a long shot so
you know mj over tj i think is is part
of the the slogan that we have
when we when we buy this thing but um if
they're doing this much
in traffic i got to know is there
something else meaning like are these in
really hot like
popular areas uh where there's already
just a lot of tourists or something like
that and
this is just a pit stop because you know
michael jordan's house in a neighborhood
you'd have to only be going to go to
this place
i looked up michael jordan's address
guess how far away it is from chicago
airport one of the most popular airports
in the world
i'm gonna guess 45 minutes
20 minutes it's 20 minutes away
okay so it's at like have you been in
memphis memphis is like
there's not that much going on in
memphis and all these people are going
to memphis
um people are chicago's what the fifth
most populous city in america or maybe
third something like that
something is interesting here so what i
would do is i wouldn't do the nft
thing i would raise uh two or three
million dollars from a bunch of rich
people
um or i would try to use my own money if
i had two or three million dollars that
i wanted to spend on this and
i would buy it and then it would
probably cost a fair bit of money
to get it set up it would probably cost
a lot of money
another many more millions but then
you'd have to convince
collectors to lend you
the stuff and you create a michael
jordan museum yes
and that's how you do this and the
companies that we've just mentioned
graceland monticello and um mount
vernon so those obviously those
folks lived in the 1700s or probably
died in the 1800s
so they've been around those properties
have been around as tourist destinations
for a hundred plus
years but they've done 50 million
revenue which is a [__] ton but even if
you've just um two or three million
dollars in revenue
and you could do that and adjust for
inflation for 50 plus years kind of like
graceland has done it for 60 years
that's incredibly fascinating right yeah
i'm with you so so i think you you know
you're [__] on the nft thing a
little bit but it's not about nft what
i'm saying is
crowdfunding um so i think that there's
a benefit to crowdfunding which is that
crowdfunding is a way to make the story
more viral
um it is a it's a more pr worthy story
that
uh you know people from the internet
people from reddit whoever got together
and bought michael jordan's home off the
market for
for 15 million dollars they raised 15
million dollars and bought the house
versus a rich guy went to his rich
friends and raised some money the second
thing is those become
you know the your evangelist to spread
the word and to come
make the uh the pilgrimage to go see
michael jordan's house
and i think you could do two or three
things with it i think you could make it
a museum that's like a modern museum
that we've been talking about like
the museum of ice cream or something
like that where
the tour is very heavy um photo based
and so you're you know you're going
through and it's all these different
photo exhibits
of you know you in michael jordan's bed
and you know wearing you know a pair of
his air jordans or standing in a pair of
giant air jordans or something like that
and you make it like a museum of ice
cream where
you're going to walk out with you know
10 photos that are instagram worthy
at the end of it i also think give give
people background on an ice cream museum
yeah bray you can pull the latest
numbers but i think these guys uh raised
it like 100 million dollar plus
valuation
and if you if you ever go to one they're
pretty cool it's you know it's not the
most amazing thing i
honestly was a little bit disappointed
but the photos do turn out cool it's a
museum that you walk through
uh so it's like a guided path and you go
through maybe like 13 different rooms
and every room is something cool and you
get a little you know you get an ice
cream cone of some flavor
and then you can take photos next to
some like exhibit that they've set up
and the idea is not for you to look at
the art like a traditional museum
but for you to like take a photo in the
art uh and post it on instagram and
that's their marketing that's the free
marketing that they get
and so museum of ice cream oh yeah here
everybody has it they raised 40 million
they raised a 40 million dollar series a
at a 200 million dollar valuation last
year
and um and i think this could be bigger
i think this could be much much bigger
as a brand
um the other thing uh the other thing
that you could do
is uh sports cards are having this
incredible boom right now
and i think what you could do is you
could have certain collectors
put their collection um
in in the house the house could be
basically the vault
to store some of the most rare
memorabilia in the sports world
sign basketball shoes and sports cards
and that could be part of the museum and
you you
basically store it and you um you store
it for some of these collectors so i
think
i think there's a bunch of stuff you
could do to make this work but the idea
is like
can you buy this thing for 13 million
put another four or five million into um
you're getting it all set up
and then could you make five million
dollars a year could you make 10 million
dollars a year like you're saying these
other guys do
um as a pilgrimage for you know tourists
going to chicago and basketball junkies
i think the answer is definitely yes and
i think it's so
interesting um i found a i found another
example of one
and it's called the um it's called the
national trust for historic preservation
and it's a non-profit and all they do is
buy
historical buildings and their
historic i looked at their numbers
they've been doing like 50 or 60 million
in revenue for years
and i'm still trying to figure out how
to entirely read
uh non-profit statements but they have a
buy a line item that's revenue
less expenses which i guess that just
means prop i mean i don't know how they
define
yeah i don't know how they define either
of those
but it was 26 million and it's been
doing that for years
is that nuts so i like this idea i like
this idea a lot and i kind of want to
dig a little further into how these
um homes home museums work because i
think this is pretty interesting the
other good thing about this by the way
is that the basketball hall of fame
sucks uh nobody cares about it nobody
goes to visit it
um all the other sports like you know
canton for football
these are like tourist destinations you
know tons of people go there every year
it's really cool and the basketball one
is
known to be super lame because they let
way too many people in
and um and it's not like it's not a
thing that basketball fans really care
to go do
can i give you two more examples that we
what we could consider doing instead of
even doing a museum maybe this is even
simpler yeah
so i'm staying at my friend jack's house
it's a badass house
um five doors down or ten doors down
something like that
nearby is what's they call it the obama
house
and when obama was in office from uh
when was he in office
oh the oh the second the second term
um or whatever it was he would stay at
this house
down here and the owners let him stay i
think for a massive discount
now it's like it has its own wikipedia
page and it's called like the obama
house
and it sold 10 years ago for 7 million
after he had already stayed there which
sorry 7 million i said i say 7 for 7
million
which is a lot of money but they rent it
out right now on airbnb for six
thousand dollars a night or
if it's booked all the way up 180k a
month and it's branded as the obama
house
i think that you could absolutely crush
it with a jordan
airbnb house would you and a group of
friends be willing to pull together
three thousand dollars a day to stay
there maybe i think the way you'd have
to do it
is you'd have to make it like a vegas
alternative
for bachelor parties and stuff like that
birthdays it's like
what is the man cave man dream vacation
it's like dude we're gonna go stay in
michael jordan's house
14 of us are going um and it comes with
like all the amenities and
you know all that stuff this is where
you go this is where you want to go
if you want to live like the sports
fan's dream i think you could do that
i do like the museum one better what was
the second idea you had you said you had
two
oh what wasn't the second i guess it was
more so uh
just another example the fresh prince of
bel-air house
um it's it's kind of interesting but do
you remember
living in san francisco how there's like
the what's it called the painted ladies
which is the whole the full house house
and then there's the missed out
firehouse
um i would just want to buy all these
and turn them all on so i lived a block
away from the
uh from the full house house and uh
literally 24 7 there is somebody
standing outside of that house during
the daytime
uh taking a photo of it so there's just
a constant and it's not like it's not
like a huge line of people
but there's always like four people
standing outside taking a photo in front
of the full house house
every single day for the whole year it's
kind of crazy and then it just sold
actually
and it's sold at basically like i think
1.5 or 2x
the market rate in that area so um they
got basically like a double
premium because it is the full house
house which i think is you know kind of
interesting
um but okay i think we should uh i think
we should buy michael jordan's house i
think we should crowdfund
uh i think we should crowdfund five
thousand people together we should own
this thing
or we could go to rally road and we
could say hey rally
let's put michael jordan's house on
rally and uh
you know let's sell this baby out i
think if five thousand
right now if you go on rally roads
you'll get two thousand or three
thousand people buying
a fractional share of you know a pair of
jordans or a signed autograph or a
signed rookie card or something like
that
[__] all that let's own the guy's house
so i think you could easily get 5000
people on rally road
to buy a fractional share of michael
jordan's house i'm surprised they don't
already do this
if they're listening to this uh you know
go go for it just give us credit
and give me a share of the house
i actually think that they wouldn't do
that because how do you liquidate that
it's been on the market for 20
or how long 10 years no one is obviously
no one's buying it
so like how do you get liquidity from
that after seven years i don't think you
don't i think
the game right the point of rally is
that they take things that are not
assets
and they make them not liquid assets
they make them liquid assets so because
you can own a fractional share
now there's liquidity any one person who
owns a piece of michael jordan's house
can swap it for anybody else who wants
to own a piece of it so you don't need a
15 million dollar buyer
because you can sell them in blocks of a
thousand or fifteen hundred dollars
and so when you bring that price point
down there's people who
wanna own a piece of the a piece of the
art a piece of the asset
which is how they do like you know
they'll sell
um you know a harry potter first edition
signed you know set of books and uh you
know instead of selling it for 25 000
they'll get you know 2 000 investors to
each put in or whatever whatever the
math comes out to
150 bucks to go buy uh you know to own a
piece of that thing
so they introduce liquidity by making it
fractionally owned
yes but there's still no cash flow you
have to create an operation around this
cash flow there's no cash in a
basketball card there's no cash flow and
air jordans there's no cash flow and
and harry potter first asian investor
who's willing to buy it
no dude you're still thinking like the
old world you haven't seen what's going
on in raleigh you're staying with jack
smith you should go ask jack smith about
how this stuff works uh he's the one who
who taught me and he's
one of the biggest investors in this
stuff he's not buying it for cash flow
um you know he's buying it because yeah
there are there is another there is
another collector and when you make it
fractional
now way more people can get in on
collecting it versus
just the rich deep pocketed people who
could buy the whole asset 100
yeah bro but who lik who liquidates it
after a
handful of years on rally road uh
someone actually buys the car
after a few years very rarely
occasionally somebody comes and offers
to buy out the whole
the whole lot um and then they put it to
a vote i don't know if you've seen this
but like you know let's say a box of
pokemon cards went on there uh like a
super rare pokemon card set
they i don't know what the ip what the
ipo was but on rally they ipo owed it
let's pretend it was 50 000
and then what happened is a is a big you
know asian investor came in and said
we'll buy this thing out for 85 000 now
so you'll all get a profit
but we want to own this thing and they
put it to the vote of all the share
owners and they said no they said we're
going to hold it we think it's going to
go up
so they voted no they voted to keep it
so they're not all trying to liquidate
um soon you know some some people who
are buy and hold investors will
want to own these assets for a long time
because they think hey you know if i
just hold this now
you know what's michael jordan going to
be what's michael jordan's fame going to
be
20 years from now if michael jordan
passes away how much is going to be
worth
and uh there's people who are in it for
the long term so
i think there's i think the collectibles
thing is a little bit different than i
think about it differently than you do i
would say
you basically need jordan to have like a
tragic accident
or like for example dance came out so so
the last dance is ten part documentary
that came out
on netflix and espn um you know millions
and millions of people watched this
thing and jordan's brand you could see
all the price of jordans went up
jordan's like brand visibility and brand
sentiment went up
um because this documentary came out and
he's still alive it wasn't a tragic
event
but somebody told the jordan story to
the the younger generation who
you know grew up where you know they
were two years old when jordan was at
his prime
and so jordan brand got stronger with
the last dance coming out
and i think that's just going to
continue you know over time because he's
got all these different
you know the legacy becomes bigger than
the person itself
but i have a different thing that's
sports related okay
yeah can i do this one so the different
thing that's sports related and
ties into the idea of um making assets
out of things making liquid assets out
of things that were non-liquid assets
so there's this company called big
league advance did you see this thing
no keep going all right i'm looking it
up so um so
shout out to uh joe pompliano uh you
know pomp's pomp's brother
one of one of his brothers um who you
know does these twitter threads all the
time so he did this twitter thread that
caught my eye
and it was about this player fernando
tatis so this guy's one of the young
i don't follow baseball anymore because
baseball's slow and boring to me now but
i used to and you know back in the day i
remember fernando tatis
his is that for is it for nano testing
junior because
okay when i was a kid the senior played
in st
louis and he was like a huge deal i
think he hit like
he hits three grand slams in one inning
and he was like our hometown hero for
years
okay that sounds crazy but um uh yeah
basically this guy's like one of the
youngest star baseball players and now
like
um he you know signed one of the big
contracts he signed a 340 million dollar
deal
with the padres and the interesting
thing that came out of that was
that this company that i had never heard
of called big league advance
made 30 million dollars off of that deal
so who who is big league advanced so
basically what these guys do is
they go to minor league baseball players
of which there are thousands
and they say look you're making you know
you don't make [__] in in the minor
leagues
um you you know you you're riding the
bus you you get paid nothing
um and you're hoping to one day get to
the league and you're hoping one day to
become a star you're hoping for the
fernando t
story where someday you'll sign a huge
contract and what they do is they go and
they offer you a deal so they'll say
like
hey we'll give you a hundred thousand
dollars
for one percent of your future earnings
so it's an income share agreement like
we've talked about with lambda school
and whatnot
and they'll go and they'll say you know
three hundred fifty thousand dollars for
eight percent of all your future
earnings
so we'll bet on you we'll take a risk on
you so you get some money today you can
give your family a better life today you
don't have to keep like
roughing it while you work your way up
but hey if you hit it big like we're
going to get paid out
and they basically do a bunch of
analytics on their side to try to
guess which players to invest in what
what what is the exact deal to offer
them
so it's like a startup investor who's
coming up with the valuation of every
minor league baseball player
and um they know they'll lose many money
on like 80 percent of the deals that
don't pan out
and they're hoping that the 20 that do
turn into
huge returns like a fernando tethy's
junior and so
um i think this is an awesome idea this
actually is similar to
a company that we've talked about called
pipe pipe is uh
they basically take companies that have
sas revenue
and they say hey you got all the sas
revenue um let's turn that into a
tradable
investable asset let's take your
contracts you have with customers
let's make it so that anyone can just
buy some of your sas contracts off you
and uh you get money today up front for
for those contracts you don't have to
wait the 12 months for for your customer
to pay you every month
and um and for that that investor
they're going to get a premium you know
so
they'll pay you the years worth of the
contract and in exchange they get like a
return on on their money and you get
money up front which you can reinvest
into your business
so i really like these companies that
are taking things that were not
investable tradable assets and making
them investable tradable assets and i
think big league advance is a cool one
because it
it's basically betting on minor league
players that might turn into stars what
do you think of this
well i'm looking at their website so how
can a minor le does that ruin the
amateur stat or is there still amateur
status with an uh my monday is pro
minder league is is that you're a pro
you're a professional player you're part
of a team's farm
system and you get paid you're out of
the college system by then by then
so you can only do the you can't do this
for college kids
correct that's cool so i think that you
i'm looking at their website now so you
i imagine this would work for
golf baseball tennis basketball
tennis i guess anything that's like
crazy numbers related right like you can
kind of like
i wonder which sports do you think are
the most predictive in terms of
baseball is known to be the most
predictive um and
the most like kind of statistically
modelable because
your teammates kind of don't matter when
you're up there batting it's just you
and there's no like team dynamics
whereas in basketball a player can be
better or worse because there's five
other people on the court
all moving around and it all affects
each other but you know
that doesn't really matter in this case
but here what you're basically saying is
let's say there's a like this guy
spencer dinwiddie tried to do this on
the nets
he um he he had signed like let's call
it a 30 million dollar contract
and what he tried to do was offer people
um
token shares in his future so he said
look i
i think i'm today i'm a like a b-level
player i think i'm going to be an
all-star someday
so if you invest in me now you'll get a
share of my future contract
and so you're just betting on a player
you're just saying i think that this
player is going to be a star
and i think this player is going to earn
this much in his career so i will
um i'll invest now in an income share
agreement of his future earnings
and so for the player they get money up
front they don't have to wait to earn
their contracts and they get a little
bit of insurance like if anything
happens they get hurt or
you know something bad happens in their
career hey at least they didn't risk it
all they got paid some up front
and for a fan it's a way to kind of bet
and invest in players that you think are
going to have more future earnings than
uh than
what they're offering today as a
valuation
this is so amazing i'm looking at their
uh so they've raised 150 million dollars
i think that
from the looks of it it looks like they
only have like
30 employees do you think that's
accurate and if they made 30 million
from
from this this one guy alone so this was
like the big home run um
and you know they've had other things
where like they they got sued by a
player because they offered him 360 000
for ten percent of his future earnings
and then he
you know he tried to sue them being like
oh [__] that was like a predatory deal
i didn't want to give up ten percent of
my all my future earnings for just 360 k
but in actuality the guy only made 1.2
million in his career so it actually
turned out to be a profitable deal
you know he took 360k up front and ended
up only paying 120k out
uh to these guys in the end so so he
dropped his lawsuit
why why is there so little information
about these guys online you think
there's really not a lot of flying like
face page
they're not a tech company uh it's just
a financing company basically
they um they tried to fly under the
radar they also got like kind of
disavowed like the
major league baseball doesn't like them
the players association said we do not
like con
we don't like like we don't say that
this is a good thing
but for the player you know it's they're
cutting a deal with an individual player
and um and i guess it's allowed in
baseball whereas in basketball
the nba blocked the thing i was talking
about they blocked spencer dinwiddie
from
tokenizing his future contract and and
basically selling off
future future earnings so some leagues
are not allowing it but major league
baseball
still uh still does allow it and minor
league baseball still allows it
so my question is this and you're more
of a sports guy than i am
and i'm looking at this and it seems
awesome
my question is what actually would make
this fail and not work well
so bad predictions so you invest in a
bunch of players that don't pan out you
could go underwater like
i don't know i don't know how favorable
their um
i don't know how much room margin of
safety they have when they do this stuff
like with startups for example just like
just like startup investing
a lot of people um are angel investors
or a lot of
you know average vc funds actually
can't even beat the stock market in
terms of returns and um
they're illiquid and they're risky and
they don't they don't outperform
and so it really comes down to these
guys ability to pick and value players
accurately
um if they can't do it well they're
going to go they're going to go broke
and if they can do it well they're going
to make a bunch of money and i think
that's
a healthy setup
how challenging is it to to do this
because
i don't know anything about sports but i
feel like
this whole moneyball thing seems kind of
like table stakes at this point
for for professional teams right
i don't think it's that challenging to
be honest with you i think that there's
uh you know you're getting you're
collecting data all the time you have
scouts you have all these different ways
to value players
and in this case it's such an
inefficient market because the minor
league players just make nothing and the
baseball teams don't want to pay them a
lot
it's like hey dude you know do you want
to live out your dream or not
and so we'll pay you the absolute
minimum required for you know just to
have you in our minor league system
and so what these guys are doing that's
smart is they're taking a percentage of
all the future earnings
and uh and so i think they're they're
basically going up against nobody right
now
but i think and i think there's even an
easier way to do this in the nba because
the nba has guaranteed contracts
so let's say i sign a five-year 100
million deal i'm an nba star
cool that means i'm going to get 20
million dollars a year uh dripped to me
and so somebody could come and offer
this guy 80 million dollars up front or
75 million dollars up front lump sum
here's your money today and uh good you
can use that you can go ball out
nba does the nba does the nba have big
as big of a minor league they i know
they have the d league but i feel like
i know so many i've got three friends
that go into minor league baseball
yeah so the nba g league is not anywhere
near like
all baseball players stars and don't
stars and not go through minor league
baseball
stars in the nba go straight to the nba
they skip the g league g-league is like
journeyman
and so um it you wouldn't do this with
minor league in the nba you'd do it with
the actual
nba athletes and for them what you would
be doing is saying
cool you're on your first contract i'm
betting that your second and third
contract are going to be bigger
and i'm willing to pay you up front on
this multi-year contract because hey
it's guaranteed you could go and break
your leg tomorrow
and you're still going to get all this
money from your team so
the nba has guaranteed contracts so it's
way less risky
uh you could just say look i'll give you
this money up front so you can go invest
it and you can go ball out you go
buy your mom a house you can go buy that
buy that i think you always wanted
um and in exchange i want to get some
some margin
on the because i'm willing to wait the
four or five years for your contract to
play out
and i can bet on your next contract and
i can you know give you some future
some money today in exchange for some
percentage of your future because i
think you're going to be a star
i i think that this is this is awesome
would you value this at a software
company because
how like if it's like a if the light if
the average length of an
mlb or nba player i don't know what it
is but i bet it's in the
eight to ten year range which means
you're you have a really high ltv
you have i imagine a quite predictable
stream of income would you value this at
software or close to software no i don't
think so because it can't scale that's
the be the beauty of software is that it
scales sort of infinitely
and um you know for every additional
customer you have you don't have that
many additional costs
in this case i think this is more like
real estate i think it's just people as
property um you're buying this asset
this multi-family property that has this
much rent
and um it's gonna it's gonna cash flow
for this many years and so you basically
are
i think you're just buying properties
yeah but real
real estate sells for almost sas like
multiples real estate
sells at like what like a five or six
percent cap rate
yeah but software is like 50 dude like
if you go look go look at salesforce or
slack or go look at these guys multiples
you know it's it's like you're at
hubspot hubspot
is doing a billion dollars a year of top
line revenue
uh that's not profit and you know even
on the revenue i think hubspot is valid
at what it's like a 30 billion dollar
company or something like that
um so it's a 30x 30x of revenue
in that case so software has better
better multiples than real estate
sure well you want to talk about one
more thing yeah
go for it let's talk about
uh we don't have enough time i think to
really dive deep into the studio model
but i'm really interested in this so
there's two companies that i've been
eyeing
the first is atomic which is uh sorry by
this guy named jack abraham
and he has launched maybe 10
different startups one of them being
hymns which is a multi-billion dollar
company
but the more interesting person is this
guy named josh kushner
kushner his brother everyone might know
as jared kushner he's the guy who was uh
on trump's cabinet uh josh kushner is
married to this model what's his her
what's her name carly
kloss i think so he's like can
have quite of a fascinating lifestyle or
a fascinating life
but with he started um a small fun he
was born into a wealthy family so he
he had money early on invested 400 000
into instagram made a significant sum
from that
and then has since uh not invested in
companies
through his his fun but really started
them and one of them or she has two of
them
one is oscar which just went public and
his stake in that is 1.2
the other one is called cadre i think
it's called which is
a rich person's investment platform but
what do you think and the reason i
brought this up is because you kinda
had that experience a little bit like
your
uh bibo was kind of a startup studio
do you like this model of starting
companies and operating them
but doing more than one at a time or
do you think that just passively
investing is better
um okay so the thing we did which was
called monkey inferno bibo was one of
the companies inside
monkey inferno was definitely a studio
and in fact before
jack started atomic um we met up
in our office and he said hey i'm
thinking about doing this studio
tell me everything you've you've learned
good and bad about running the studio so
i can kind of learn from those mistakes
and i told him hey like here's what i
think is great here's some of the things
i think that
that trip us up um if i was you starting
from scratch here's how i would do it
and then he's you know he took that and
he wait so jack came to you
yeah he came to our office and we hung
out and we we brainstormed and i kind of
told him look
these are the strengths and weaknesses
of the studio model how are you planning
to do it
and to his credit he already what he had
as an idea coming in was already
the exact advice i was recommending and
so
it's not like oh i told him you should
do xyz then he went did it he was
already planning to do it that way
but um but yeah and at the time i was
like you know good luck because
very few studios there are many many
studios the studio is like
the the reason studios happen is like
successful entrepreneur
wins they take some of their lottery
winnings and they're like all right [__]
it i'm gonna do a studio this time
because i can't pick one idea and i just
want to do a bunch of [__]
i want to do a bunch of cool things and
like now i have my own money i don't
need other investors so much or i can
i can easily raise money from investors
because i have this big reputation
and so you saw you know garrett camp the
co-founder of uber he starts a studio
mark pincus the founder of zynga he
starts a studio kevin rose that you know
sold his company
to google then he starts a studio uh
michael burch does bebo sells it to aol
he started the studio that i i ran um
you know
there's a whole bunch of these guys that
do this stuff and very few of them have
success
um we didn't have any breakout wins
um garrett camp from uber he didn't win
mark pincus he didn't win kevin rose he
didn't win so
so you know there was for a long time
there was literally
zero like breakout winners from studios
and recently there's been a few
that have worked atomic has had a few
that have worked hymns is like the big
win for them it's a
public company now i believe and uh
multi you know a multi-billion dollar
win that they incubated in their studio
um then there's uh the bark uh barkbox
guys so they think they're in their
studio is called pre-hype
so they they you know they took barkbox
uh public
and um they've done very well and i
think they also have uh
row which is a competitor to him so now
there's been a few like
there's somebody got on the scoreboard
so it definitely can work
uh i would say the odds are that studio
thrive
and now thrive yeah thrive with oscar
going public is great
um and so i would say the odds are still
you know it's just like startups where
startups 90 of startups you know fail
similar uh similar odds with the studio
it's not like you get that much better
um i would say a couple things super fun
to do
because who wouldn't want this it's like
an entrepreneur's playground you get to
go to work
dream up ideas you have a t you have a
bunch of teams that are building them
all in parallel
in theory you're killing the losers and
you're doubling down on the winners
and uh you know you're just being super
creative every day so it's like the
dream job
then does it do you actually increase
your odds of success
on one hand yes because you're getting
multiple shots on goal you're not you
don't have all your eggs in one basket
with one idea
the second thing is that you're learning
pretty rapidly so you're learning from
all these different reps these different
attempts you're doing
and you're keeping the team together so
like when a team
even if you fail the team retains those
learnings and just applies it to the
next project right away
whereas in a normal startup if you fail
it's like everybody goes and gets a job
for two years because now you're
you know you just did this thing for
three years it didn't work you're in
debt you need to go make some money
and so typically the team breaks up and
goes and does something else
in this case the team sticks together
the learnings are retained so that's
that's what's good the bad part which i
think is what you're gonna focus on
the big butt of this whole model that i
think is what makes it not a great idea
if you
if you're if you're optimizing for
success i don't think this is the best
way
is uh you're not focused because you
have multiple ideas
and you know one of the benefits of one
of the key things in life is
is focus and laser focus on on making
something successful
and the second thing which is kind of
related to that is like shiny object
syndrome
every project goes through like kind of
periods of plateaus like i remember with
the hustle
you started off you know with the events
then you started the blog
and then like there was a moment i
remember our conversations where you
were like
the blogs are bringing in a bunch of
traffic but i don't think this is
working
i need to figure out something else what
if i did this daily email newsletter
right you were like trying to figure out
what do we do is it video is it this
newsletter what is it
and in a studio when that happens when
you plateau or things just stop working
or
growth stalls it's super easy to instead
of being like [__] how do we find a way
out of this how can we try to make this
work
uh it's really easy to be like hey what
about that other idea that we're doing
like that one's still super exciting
it's not in a plateau right now
so you just like unconsciously start to
spend more energy on the thing that's
not stuck
because like who wants to stay in a
[__] stuck on a stuck project
but as an entrepreneur you have no
choice you told everybody you told your
investors you told your team
you told your mom i am building this and
you have to find a way
and that's like the most valuable thing
a startup has is that like
the the the do or die situation for a
startup and i think
studio takes away the do or die
mentality because it's like do this or
do that
or do that or do the other thing and so
you have all these options and those
options
actually um they actually take away your
biggest asset as a startup so i would
say
if you're going for fun studios are dope
if you're going for success
i think that going like dabbling and
picking a startup to go
all in on is a better model than trying
to run a studio with multiple projects
and that's actually what i remember my
what i spoke to you about
um years ago when we started hanging out
at monkey inferno
is uh i don't remember which one it was
blab bebo one of them
like it seemed pretty good but like
every business there was some problems
where you're like
people are coming but we're getting
hacked or i don't remember what the
problem was yeah
or it was like kind of good kind of bad
um and
i was like dude just like just
figure it out and i actually thought
that you were
for part of me was like oh sean's at
this great place where he can do
anything he makes money and he has an
unlimited budget he can do anything
i actually think that that hurt a lot of
times
and it would have been a little bit
better if it was like
look if you don't figure this out you're
you're you're [__] you're broke
right yeah exactly i think you you
called it for what it was like really
early on you were like dude i think
having everything right we had like a
[__] private chef
we had the dopest office we had all the
engineers we needed we had unlimited
funding and runway we could just keep
going
and you were like dude it's gonna make
you soft like don't
you know having all this [__] is like
not good for you i remember you like
pointing that out really early on
and then also like just pick one of
these and stick to it don't like
don't get distracted by having a lab or
a studio where you have all these
different things going on
and you're just dividing up your
attention 20 here 30 here 10
here and uh like what if you just put
into like the one and you just found a
way you know i
you i remember you saying that stuff
but it seems really fun
and when it works it's like oh wow it
worked
and it's fun and that's what i'm seeing
when i when i when i
i mean i don't know these guys but from
an outside perspective and i'm sure it
sucks on the inside just like everything
else has pros and cons
it seems quite fun it seems really
exciting to be able to win big
and have multiple uh shots on target
it seems really interesting um so one
thing by the way one thing i think
atomic did good
uh that they changed the model so he was
i told him i was like
i told him about these problems and he
was like yeah we're gonna do it
differently he's like we're gonna only
do
one project at a time that team
is do or die on that project he goes
they have nine months to raise their
their series a and if they can't raise
their series a in nine months
they're out like you're out of a job and
he's like in reality we're gonna keep
the good people we're gonna offer them a
job on the next one
but like it's not a given that like oh
if this doesn't work no problem like
just work on this other thing that we're
doing
and he's like that's going to have
urgency that's going to have focus
they're not going to split their time
between different projects and he's like
i'm going to be the ceo of of the
project you know like that we're doing
and
the other big thing was they weren't
going after consumer like we were doing
consumer and like social apps which are
you know lower odds of of hitting the
lottery
um whereas he was like yeah consumer's
super hard you know it's just really
hard to
you know the consumers are fickle we're
gonna do b2b and so that they started
doing only b2b stuff
for a long time and um and hims was the
one kind of like consumer
hit that they've had um the other things
that they've had that have done okay are
b2b companies which i think are
a smarter model to do e-founders is a
great example of one of the that's
working in europe
where it's like they only do sas and
they really focus on
problems that they know that are in the
b2b space because their own companies
have this problem
so then they build a product for that
and they build it make a company out of
it they've had big hits like front
came out of that and different things
like that
well rocket internet does it as well and
they're they have their tens of billions
of dollars with the value that they've
created but the best example of this my
favorite actually and i just realized
this
as we were talking is kevin ryan kevin
ryan
is someone who i admire and and i i joke
that we kind of look like he's
probably uh 30 years older than me
but i tease that we like he kind of
looks like i look like him we kind of
look alike
and he um he was the 20th employee at
i forget what it was called but it was
double click it was called doubleclick
and it was sold to google for
multi-billions and eventually became
google adwords and adsense and he told
me that he made around 20 million
dollars when he sold it
which was definitely a [__] ton of money
and then using that him and this guy
named dwight would
invest 300 000 and give a company six
months
to show traction and the outcome of
their companies
uh there's a a couple losers and a
couple winners
probably a lot more losers than winners
but the first one is mongodb
which is currently publicly traded at a
21 billion valuation
the second one is business insider which
is probably a bill
it was sold for 500 million dollars
probably worth a lot more now
uh the third one is zola which prior to
the pandemic was doing hundreds of
millions of dollars in sales
and i think that there's like four or
five more that have been hits
right and he told me i actually called
him and i emailed him like
every month for like three years to try
and get him to talk to me and eventually
he let me fly out there and meet with
him
and he told me that all he does is him
and dwight i mean they're wealthy right
so they can do this but they
he they just come up with an idea and
they just get a piece of paper and a
pencil and they like write out the math
and they're like oh that's kind of
interesting all right let's try to find
someone to do it and we'll give them
300k
to do it now this sounds like a very
simple process and it might be simple
but it's still quite hard to pull off
but they've done it and it's and it's
called um sil
uh silicon alley insider it's the name
of his thing
and uh you'll have to look this guy up
it's really interesting i think that's
jason calacanis
thing that's not that's not those guys
no it's it's they have the same name
oh okay interesting um it's it's called
uh
wait is it called silicon alley insider
uh it's called the alley corp
sorry you're right it's called ali corp
so so i think there's
a business insider was called silicon
alley insider interesting so so i think
um
so so there's it's just like
accelerators right there's like a
million accelerators in the world every
college has one every little city has
one
and then you have y combinator that just
like kicks ass and you know so what
combination
best sorry to interrupt guilt guilt
guilt is the other one that he started
right go ahead that's a bunch of hits so
basically you have like
it's not that is this model good or bad
it's like how do you execute it and who
are the people involved in it so like
y combinator is an accelerator that is
probably created
you know i don't know 100 billion
dollars worth of value now out of the
companies that have come out of it
um easily over 100 billion actually
airbnb alone is 100 billion
um so so y combinator is like the best
and then you have tech stars and then
you have like all these other
accelerators that like have never had a
hit
and um so our accelerator model is good
or bad like if you said it was bad
you'd be wrong because y combinator is a
hit but if you said it's
just great and you can repeatably make
success using this model no that's not
true
i think the same is true for studios and
everyone is different because you have
to make a bunch of choices it's like
for example are you going to do multiple
ideas at once or you're going to do one
at a time
are you going to have shared staff
working across projects you're going to
have staff dedicated to their one and
they live and die with the one
are you going to fund it indefinitely or
you're going to give it a six month or
nine month
time period to to get to some traction
and raise money from external investors
or are you just going to let it run
forever do you come up with the ideas or
do you
invite in founders and they spend some
time coming up with the idea like an eir
all right there's all these different
differences that like there's all these
like little choices that will lead to a
totally different outcome
it sounds like in that case they come up
with the ideas and then they find an
operator
in jack's case he came up with ideas and
he was the initial operator and then he
hires a ceo
um you know in xbus case they bring in
an operator and they
the operator comes up with the idea and
so there's all these different
versions of it and um you know a lot of
it just depends on both luck
as well as who's involved like truly
great entrepreneurs and investors can
have success where somebody else copying
the same model that they have
won't they won't be able to pull it off
because they don't have the right
judgment
and that's why i think i failed and i
think i didn't have the same judgment
that
these guys who have had success like
with them with their model i think they
were better at playing that game than i
was
it also helps to be wealthy i think and
be able to write
uh 10 to 20 300 000
checks and have the time to do it and so
i don't want to dismiss that
but a lot of them raise money like jack
he raised money he raised uh i don't
know like 100 million dollars or
something from andrews and horowitz and
others
to fund his lab even though he himself
was like you know you know
doing super well he had sold the company
to ebay he was like
crushing it at paypal or whatever like
or ebay when he was there
um you know he sold his company for 75
million dollars when he was 24. well i'm
not just
i'm not dismissing any of their skill
i'm just saying this is definitely like
a
after you get your hit it's a lot easier
i'm not dismissing that at all it's like
it's a lot easier to become a good
golfer if you have some money to afford
a fancy
uh uh fancy clubs and a membership and
there's a bunch of people trying to do
this
that don't have that right there's a
group uh this guy bobby he listens to
the podcast he's doing this for creators
he's like all right
we're gonna make a studio we're gonna
just build products for the creator
economy
and i don't think they have a big track
record or anything like that but that's
their focus they're trying to do a
studio for that i'm not saying it's
impossible
i know another group of guys this year
another group of guys that i'm bet i
would bet on
that um the main guy is this guy kumar
and uh if you should follow him on
twitter he's amazing uh he's super
interesting on twitter and facebook uh
his handle is
data raid i know who he is and he's just
like really into
all these alternatives he's a weird guy
yeah he's a weird dude but he's really
sharp and he's
really out there different type of
thinker and so he's like
he's like really into like you know the
the energy industry
and so he'll build like little products
for the energy industry that you didn't
even know
like there was a need for so i think
this guy's going to do well because
he knows where to sniff he knows where
to sniff out some money because
he's looking at problems that the
average kind of engineer
in silicon valley or new york or la they
don't even know these
problems exist they don't even know
these companies exist and so um
you know he's he was doing one for
example like his friend is a lawyer
and uh you know there's like all these
like little rule changes in
like your local regulation or your local
law and he just made an alert system
where it'll alert you about whenever
this rule changes
and uh he can go get a bunch of lawyers
to sign up for these email alerts
and it's a sas business that you know
can do well or
you know energy prices when they when
they rise and fall
um how you know how are you gonna track
that how do you get how do you build a
database of that that information
so he's got all these like really random
ideas that i think the average
entrepreneur doesn't really even know
about those markets enough to like
to know those problems and therefore he
finds kind of untapped opportunities
well i think we should dive deep on this
sometime
like even more and i want to get jack on
here and i would love to get kevin ryan
on here
um because i this sounds cool it
definitely sounds like a rich guy's
playground and frankly i want to do it
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
the days of
the road